highly Jenna who is I believe fake boobs
fake ass and faked hips fake job fake
nose fake lips everything this girl fake
puss if she's tucked we don't even know
she's tucked right right right they push
maybe lips this girl's technically more
real yeah
not more girl but more real than kylie
100% so have all these girls in there
plastic surgery the hollywood plastic
surgery aesthetic if you will mmm-hmm
have they opened the door to us cracking
open [ __ ] because they're just as
fake or just as real or women meeting
trainees halfway and now it's become so
like normalizing we're so used to body
parts not being real that once we see a
dude with some body parts and all real
were like well it's no different than
last girl I dated it's a problem
I'm just saying Brazilian trans lives
matter trans would make the most sense
out of all this bro it's so true son
this is the most walk he's ever been to
you really want to [ __ ] do right now
I don't want to [ __ ] do I wanna [ __ ]
that single guy to get some [ __ ] talk
this guy right here
no doubt no [ __ ] if he gets out of
bed too early when I'm not done cuddling
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you kidding me yo she bad she bad
you're like aggressive over here
quiet over here yes bro is true
sometimes you need one to change like
white people like black people can't
play baseball and Jackie Robinson who
built this big I mean no the
Frankenstein doctor put her together we
come on this is a bomb as doctor out
there in Brazil this is the role modeled
man this is what it is now Brooke he's
the tempura [ __ ] then take it down
yes yes wait you would let her split it
open you let you just shocked you let
her shook heck she got some oysters for
dinner with the red sauce
[Laughter]
traffic I didn't understand what the
metaphors but now I understand answers
yes it's a white listen you can't say no
I literally wish we could do callings
right now I wish we could have anybody
later no lying
so here's thing you're saying no cuz you
know if you didn't know you're taking it
down yeah think about if you didn't
knows a dude you [ __ ] uglier girls in
that aisle of course
[ __ ] the majority I feel confident
saying that you can even say I got a
thing for ugly [ __ ] voices back by
the way I don't have that wrong we
should get us tested right antibodies
get hurt else for a y-chromosome do man
[Applause]